aha here we go Grandmaster dr. John none
so what do we get maybe I should have
played c4 I don't like to give the the
big center here so okay let's try to
take it with c4 go deform let's see if
he goes efore a niche oh okay it doesn't
yeah I try together get in i QP
positioner that's nice now that's a nice
transposition to a good i QP let me
think about it i think Bishop e3 is good
it's a transposition to the towel rush
now but in a slightly less reliable form
for black let's see what happens the
drawback of that maneuver is that I have
Bishop c5 after night see form I
actually had that in a tournament game
once okay what is this why can I not
cheek d5
huh
hmm that looks it looks slightly
unharmonious to take it but I don't see
right now why not actually at the end
what is the point let's do that okay if
it is not working he will show me I
don't don't get it check hmm that's
enough compensation really nights you
forward interesting
hmm i don't i don't believe that i don't
believe that this is enough Bishop t4
maybe he has activity absolutely but
enough activity hmm my doubts jun 23 or
queen bee three I couldn't be 392 ok
yeah I know maybe it's enough it's
pretty active it's pretty active but
hmm I don't snap I didn't believe that
sorry I if I get in like b3 and III it's
really just a pawn for absolutely
nothing so wants to trade here so i take
c 5 yeah that might be active because be
to us but i can go be through so i can
go be three in this position and first
send that night back
and I want to go look see one next in
case of a night retreat and I wonder i'm
wondering if I am overlooking some kind
of tactic here and now I wanted to go
rook see one Roxy one Bishop takes Queen
takes looks okay
if I get some other if I get the Queen
no instead okay I'm Bishop c5 queen d 3
CD 395 lat tech might be might be some
kind of compensation Quincy for maybe
leave him I'm a bit so slow here quite
unnecessary I think that they were
probably a couple of these and
continuations and I'm playing it a bit a
bit too slow so and it's coming let's
take him it should be should be okay
so you get the night to see three maybe
ok flick that in III 494 that was that
was an idea anyway
Knight takes g3 as a funny idea
sometimes you can take f3 then hmm
interesting what about 94 is this on or
94 look see 290x f5 not clear if this is
helping our queen bee three will
actually take them so let's go here I'm
just far too slowly i come on let's play
a bit quicker you don't do know
sometimes sometimes I'm flop falling
asleep here okay like I'm 195 coming
checking h2 ok so now here I can take
the form so maybe a for Queen a 5 mm
looks dangerous
dangerous but it shouldn't be fatal
really
shouldn't be but maybe I'm unless to
meeting it i miss underestimated it okay
check check first and ask questions
later night f5 here I Roxy five actually
Roxy five is strong I think does he have
some lube before crazy idea no doesn't
check can I just move it tink and then
quindi one is really on but I have
worked you five I cannot calculate now I
have no time check what a shame check I
can go king of six or even that one ah
no I can eat it just covered yeah for
the splat I just hell I just fell asleep
in that draw I of course not wait for
heads I wanted to resign now came the
desert totally stupid loss he just gave
away a born for no compensation and I'm
just winning just shouldn't check let
the clock run back so Knight f3 is at
this one King here quintic so what does
win rook air-five and over that does win
yeah Quinn somewhere I at only 10
seconds and then then you really cannot
cannot go anywhere
I think he's just a pawn down here I
really don't don't don't think it this
is a serious serious enough compensation
the issue is the time spent i mean i can
play all of those moves basically almost
instantly there is no need to spend that
time it's all relatively relatively easy
to play and entirely unnecessary if I
thought this this was on maybe something
like that chatting like here might have
to I don't know it this is always a bit
tricky but came check on losing it is
kind of embarrassing even even the even
King moves I think to just win I mean
what you see with what is she doing now
and this year here I hesitated because I
saw that this is good because where's
the Queen going and that's actually much
easier when it's the Queen going test no
move oh ok so lucky win here for the doc
I guess ok well thanks for watching